the mayor of Reno declared last Saturday
anti Jim Jeffries day this isn't a joke
the mayor of Reno and it's because of
something that you did why don't you
tell us what you did on my show i told i
begged kim jeong-hoon to bomb reno to
save la yard because if he bombed la we
all die I thought Reno could sacrifice
themselves for us so thank you la yeah
what was your logic
what was your logic behind choosing Reno
well I had a gig coming up in Reno and I
thought I could plug the show at the
same time we gave the coordinates to
Reno and then our legal department rang
up said you can't give the exact
coordinates because if Reno gets bombed
you'll be blamed so what we did was we
gave 40 miles outside of Reno so Lake
Tahoe that'll be gone yeah the people in
Reno will still die a horrible slow
death same as usual for them the mayor
of Reno comes up gives me this it's an
official Park yeah this is auntie Jim
Jeffries day and the September 9th every
year and I go what happens if something
else happens is it always gonna be my
day and they go yes yeah so so something
like September 11th could happen on
September 9th and they can't switch that
day they can't switch that day will
always be my dam Rena we have the
proclamation right here this is the anti
Jim Jefferies day and then look at here
I love that they got a little digging
here in and for the City of Reno Nevada
and here's to hoping you bomb again
tonight if the biggest little they have
to give
jab they had to go for it I will Reina a
soul that shy yeah gonna speak to the
people of Reno look you deserve to live
as much I can't even finish it you're a
terrible man
you